[Música]
[Aplausos]
quando o convidaram para participar no
tedh
confesso que fiquei um bocado foi um
cara difícil encontrar as palavras para
explicar o que eu faço e motiva a fazer
o que eu faço obrigou omar foi inteiro
no confaz levar a cabo as minhas idéias
sem medo e sem receio
geralmente quando tem uma idéia eu faço
hoje uma vez que são as consequências
mais tarde mas a maior parte das vezes
têm de benefício
cheguei à conclusão que a tribo está
este medo falta bd receio lugar de onde
eu venho e quero partilhar convosco a
minha história eu lembro de ouvir a voz
da minha mãe cedo de manhã quando
tentava enquanto limpava o quintal de
bucca tcheca que nunca lenga nem mesmo é
bank bruno calenga vez em quando quando
estes papagaios traz um sorriso no rosto
do goleiro lembrou um das mãos pegajosas
pirão fazia pra colar os papéis de seda
no nas piadas bambus para fazer os
papagaios voavam centenas de metros no
ar
nós fazemos bem quer dizer que os poucos
recursos que tínhamos taxa de rama de
frutas etc e gostava eu estava muito
participar nos desenhos na areia que é
uma das tradições da minha terra um
chico brincava todo dia e quando o som e
já vou horizonte os alunos será os cães
começavam ladrarem nós corremos para
casa com medo porque acreditávamos
stange viram chegar do nosso espírito
lembro do som do estante dos batuques
vinha do outro lado do rio é não e do
cocotá cateco tocava kissanje encantava
catei com uma lanchonete ouvia falar
mitos e rituais com uma circuncisão smo
canas gula instigante mas o que mais me
atraía eram os bucks vestidos com seus
trajes com riscas caras cobertas com
máscaras quando dançavam e rodeado de
pessoas numa harmonia de sons palmas
assobios som dos batuques fazia só em
jogar pra cima e pra baixo lado do lado
para o outro movimento despejo levantava
poeira
eu lembro daquele cheiro daquela terra
vermelha quando jogava água para tomar a
poeira
tudo isso era fascinante porque enche a
minha mente com vontade de querer
compreender aquela vontade de querer
aprender e poder decifrar tudo aquilo
como rodeava e quando procurávamos aos
mais velhos
a resposta era simples um dia irá
compreender um dia irá compreender a
resposta em 1900 a aaa antes de 1975 ea
sinfonia dormir
sonhava com aquelas máscaras fantasias
máscaras dançava mas por avançar sozinho
a ciosamente pela manhã cedo pra poder
da esperança seria naquele dia queria
compreender tudo aquilo como guiava em
1975 os sonhos foram interrompidos
condições
estes são a ser uma fonte agudas graves
no seu passeio trovoadas misturadas com
faíscas e relâmpagos eram assustadores
eram os que tenham os roteiros rajadas e
assim fui obrigado a abandonar
aqui é o paraíso a pé à noite após noite
dia pois dia quilômetros após
quilômetros pelas chamas e matas
fugimos em direção à zâmbia o quanto
mais uma faixa estava sempre fechava os
olhos as cores
o cheiro as vozes do luena tornando as
cada vez mais intensos da minha mãe
dentro havia aquela esperança de tudo
aquilo era temporário
quando chegamos exame o levaram para um
lugar que chamava aeba em maio bandeira
azul macho uma tenda catanas e levaram
de roterdã entre orting era uma rua
acaba de ser feita no meio do mato
rodeado da área gigante com um máximo de
matéria que saltavam ramo
cortamos algumas árvores montamos a
nossa tenda isto no nosso próprio lado o
nosso novo lar
durante o dia queimávamos lenha para
aproveitar a acesa cunhamos a volta da
kubota da batata da tenda para sufocar o
juiz onde três goleiros buru a noite
toda no silêncio da noite aqui é o
compasso dos grilos fazia lembrar do som
dos batuques a minha mãe mesmo assim
continuava cantaram sobreviveríamos da
melhor maneira podemos até que em 1976
em maio vamos voar de e para portugal
como refugiados em lisboa
tudo era diferente as pessoas o cheiro
sabor noj entre olhávamos maneira
diferente senti a diferença que o
separava de luz
o fato fazia mais consciente da minha
identidade africana
pouco a pouco ainda tem uma nova vida
jogava futebol e nos convívios a música
ea dança alimentar o espírito
na altura estava descobrir uma nova
cultura ea cultura afro americana
esta cultura era rica em todas suas
partes ilustrava o orgulho os afro
americanos tinham pela sua cultura
também jogava futebol na altura a equipa
do estoril etapa direito duas paixões a
cultura dança e futebol
mas a dança ea música continuava no
epicentro de um universo de seguir pela
dança
fiz audição entre para o conservatório
nacional de dança lisboa com a ajuda da
minha professora da lei e conseguir
ingressar com o elenco do grupo
bailarinos de um programa de televisão
que chamava um dos trechos e se alguém
se lembra praticamente o único negro que
se via a todos os domingos era eu
certo na televisão passava uma série de
televisão que chamava femme só uma série
americana
pessoas que conhecem aquela série era
música e teatro era fascinada
certo dia a atriz principal até biehl em
de foi a portugal e deu uma aula de
dança
fiquei assoberbado em ver de perto
aquela qualidade artística aquela
qualidade movimento
fiquei a sonhar de olhos abertos e
percebemos que iria atingir aqui é um
nível teria que ir de onde ela veio no
inter e salvador e que era meses depois
quando 60 anos
bonito somente no número do fone de uma
pessoa que mal conhecia
atravessei o atlântico em busca da que é
o sonho quando cheguei nova york estava
fascinado tinha estava no meio do mundo
que tinha visto em filmes em vídeos
os arranha ceús as pessoas as cores de
nada e carlo joão franzin em todos os
cantos no metro
havia uma potência e dar ter uma coisa
incrível nas aulas de danças bailarinos
o empenho o talento era tudo que eu
imaginara
esta minha opção pela dança estilo
fascínio no amor pela cultura fazia
trabalhar sem parar e trabalhava das 11
da noite até 7 da manhã ia fazer aulas
de dança 10 novo às 15 30 que cava duas
horas a praticarem limpava estúdios em
troca de aulas até quatro anos mais
tarde entrei para uma companhia de balé
clássico porque estudava clássico mas
não alimentava minha alma
não era minha cultura os sábados
voluntária' vá pro nacional da ásia
institute uma organização de estados
unidos que trabalha com crianças e
utiliza a arte e incluir a fia tinha
aprendido que a dança ea música eram
padrões eram fórmulas matemáticas em
movimento
comecei a utilizar a matemática e
dimitria para que a classe de dança
dentre os ritmos africanos e se cria um
novo vocabulário de dança quando em 1990
fui convidado para fazer um espetáculo
nas nações unidas na assembléia geral
das nações unidas apresentaram angola
convidei crianças treinamos num parque
em arma x trás
quando apresentava o espetáculo foi foi
excelente tivemos com as duas mil
pessoas do pt bater palmas
a minha decisão não precisava ser feita
estava feita naquele momento abandonei o
clássico e comecei a trabalhar com
crianças
a partir daí espectáculos continuaram
os convites não pararam
erros e elas identificavam os com a
minha cultura foi uma surpresa para mim
porque eu fui pro estados unidos atraído
pela cultura de luz mas na verdade ela
estavam ávidos em conhecer a minha
cultura
[Aplausos]
eu tinha disputado neusa curiosidade e
em 3 sobre a minha cultura com foram foi
partilhando as minhas danças meus contos
e lendas histórias maior eo empenho e em
três deles já não era só as crianças
eram os pais eram os amigos transit que
passavam e quando podia ajudavam os
custos deste casa foi fascinado em ver o
impacto que a dança ea música estava ter
na vida deus estava criar uma estrutura
disciplinada dentro das suas vidas
estava em combinei luz estava elevarem o
orgulho africano conforme fui conhecendo
a história de lúcia ea cultura deus
consegui perceber é que apesar de
estarem separados por oceanos gerações e
conflitos de fato éramos ramos da mesma
árvore
em 1990 fundei batoto yetu significa as
nossas crianças é uma organização sem
fins lucrativos e utilizei o turismo
dança a música a cultura pretende ser a
força interior o autoestima
autoconfiança de crianças através da
cultura
hoje 30 anos quase 30 anos mais tarde
apesar de ter começado com 60 crianças
em nova york
são centenas de crianças quer nos
estados unidos portugal brasil mesmo k
que desfrutam grande carreiras e boas
vidas
uma coisa que eu não sabia que no luena
as palavras um dia irá compreender
aqui é o fascínio aquela cultura que eu
tinha aquela ansiedade que estimulava a
minha imaginação e despertou em mim o
poder da criatividade que o transportava
para que o mundo maravilhas 11 música e
dança estava em combinarem mim uma
fortuna gação cultural
o qual me identificava pela segunda vez
a dança e música estava a fazer a mesma
coisa outras pessoas que já tinham liga
tem um desligado há séculos
acredito que a nossa cultura érika
envolvente e tem uma capacidade única de
dizer uma capacidade única para
desenvolver como é que desde a
desenvolver a autoestima a força
interior que nos ajuda a ultrapassar
qualquer obstáculo na nossa vida e tem
que começar daqui tudo que eu partilho
são fragmentos da memória porque sem ela
nada sou eu
[Aplausos]
acredito que o significado das palavras
um dia irá conhecer foi ele o desafio de
aprender a decifrar o significado desta
cultura rica e preservarem da melhor
maneira possível
quero deixar a todos os presentes o
desafio sonhar em dois abertos e terem a
coragem concretizá los sem medo em cena
saiu brigado
[Aplausos]